du Canada, à Montréal où
le nombre d'étudiants issus de
la diversité a considérablement
augmenté. Voici ce qu'a constaté
Pascale Haononon Julien.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Si on commence pas à s'ouvrir,
on va mourir.
- J'ai vu des changements
énormes. Je ne travaille pas
dans la même école.
- Oui, c'est important de
des modèles qui nous
ressemblent.
- C'est ici qu'on forme
depuis plus de de 60 ans
des interprètes, des auteurs
et aussi des metteurs en scène
en théâtre, en français
et en anglais.
Certains diplômés sont devenus
de véritables vedettes au Québec
et à l'international.
On change rarement une recette
qui marche, et pourtant
une petite révolution se joue à
l'intérieur des murs de l'École
nationale de théâtre po
recruter davantage d'étudiants
issu de la diversité.
Et ça a commencé
par l'élargissement
de la définition.
GIDEONRSRSRSRS, DG,
École nationale de théâtre
- Quand on parle de diversité,
diversité culturelle, oui, mais
aussi de régions, de langues,
socioéconomiques aussi.
Alors on a fait des efforts
dans les dernières années
de s'ouvrir vers le monde.
- Et pour s'ouvrir, l'école
a tissé des liens avec des
jeunes en créant des festivals
de théâtre et en offrant des
stages de courte durée. Le but :
se faire connaître auprès de
milieux historiquement moins
ocococoches du théâtre. Et la fn
de recruter le talent a aussi
été révisée.
- On a simplement invité
du monde issu d'autres horizons
de faire partie du panel
décisionnel pour le concours
d'entrée à l'école. Ce qui veut
dire... je dis souvent,
c'est comme de changer de paire
de lunettes. Des fois, si on
porte tous les mêmes lunettes,
on peut juste voir une chose.
- Ce n'est pas un manque depassé
Ntumba à s'inscrire à l'école de
théâtre, mais plutôt une
inquiétude léguée par son père.
ZOÉ NTUMBA, étudiante, École
nationale de théâtre du Canada
- C'est quelque chose qu'il
avait trouvé très difficile,
lui, acteur noir au Québec.
l l l l l voulait pas, je pense,
que je puisse traverser
les mêmes obstacles.
- Qu'est-ce que t'as écrit?
- Je suis allée en psycho.
Il y avait rien qui me donnait
cette passion que j'ai pour
le théâtre, alors j'ai fait
mes auditions et ça a marché!
C'est la phrase qui nous laisse
savoir que le frère André,
c'est comme un méchant monsieur.
- Comment ça se passe?
- Ça se passe super bien! Moi,
j'avais beaucoup d'appréhensions
quand j'ai fait justement
mes aussssssssssssi à d'autres
écoles, mais l'École nationale
de théâtre, c'était, je pense,
l'école qui me parlait le plus,
surtout quand on parle
de diversité, quand on p
du corps professoral qui est
vraiment très... hétérogène.
J'ai eu mon stage avec
une professeure qui elle
était Congolaise, elle venait
du même pays que moi,
puis elle m'a parlé justement
de l'attrait qu'elle
à cette école-ci.
- C'est ce que ton personnage
traverse dans son histoire.
- Exact.
- Les efésésésésésésés
par la direction de l'école
ont des répercussions
que l'on peut même chiffrer.
- Du côté du programme de
"acting" du côté anglophon
on est, je dirais, toujours
à 50 à 60 % des étudiants
qui sont issus de la diversité
dans chacune des cohortes.
Cette année, du côté
francophone, je pense que
c'est rendu même à 40-50 %.
- Elle ne lui en veut plus
parce qu'elle le connaît.
- Mais en plus de repensersssss,
on passe sous la loupe
le contenu des cours.
FRÉDÉRIC DU
programme d'interprétation, ÉNT
- Cette année, on a un cours
de dramaturgie africaine
post-coloniale.
C'est des dramaturgies qu'on
n'étudiait pas, littéralement.
Je veux dire, on était vraiment
dans un discours eurocentré,
avec... avec les classiques
qu'on connaît et tout ça. Enmmms
déchirant parce que travailler
un Racine, c'est essentiel
pour un élève. Et on dit pas :
on va plus faire Racine. On dit:
qu'estetetetetetetetettre
maintenant à côté de Ra
- Là, la dynamique du groupe,
est-ce que ça change?
- Oui, forcément, ça change.
Puis ça change si la classe est
réellement représentative. Moi,n
de mettre sur le parcours de
ces jeunes-là des professeurs en
qui ils peuvent se reconnaître
aussi, c'est important.
s s s s s s s s s lesquels ils
peuvent  aussi se reconnaître,
des enjeux, qui les concernent.
- Mais bien que l'école se
transforme, la question se pose:
est-ce que le marché du travail,
lui, change au même rythme?
- C'est incroyable ce qu'on voit
maintenant dans le milieu
anglophone. C'est impossible
d'avoir assez de talents
qui sort
Alors je pense que ça s'en vient
rapidement pour le milieu
francophone.
- Bye! À demain!
- Qu'est-ce qui doit changer?
- Au-delà de juste mettre du
monde qui sont de la diversité
devant l'écran, les personnes
qui sont derrière l'écran,
ça aussi, ça doit changer.
- Zoé sait que le chemin
sera encore long avant de faire
sa place, mais le défi
ne lui fait pas peur
- Je vais pas être une pionnière
non plus parce que je sais qu'il
y en a eu d'autres avant moi,
mais de pouvoir être un symbole,
je pense, pour d'autres
personnes qui pensent que
c'est pas possible,
qui ne se voient jamais.
♪ ♪